Thanks Susan. Now, Andy, would you mind telling me and the viewers at home a
little more about this event.
&gt;&gt; Lauren, that's a great question. So, at its core what we have here is a weight
difference threshold competition. What that means is, let's say I took these
two mugs, they're identical, they have the same weight. So, if I gave them to
you right now, what would they feel like?
&gt;&gt; The same!
&gt;&gt; Right. And what if instead, I put a gram of water into one of these mugs, and
you're blindfolded, remember. Could you tell the difference?
&gt;&gt; I don't think so, it's just one gram of water.
&gt;&gt; But if there was, let's say 100 grams of water?
&gt;&gt; Yeah, I think I'd be able to tell the difference between 100 grams of water.
&gt;&gt; You probably would. So the question is, where is that threshold? At what point
can you tell the difference in weight?
&gt;&gt; How exactly are they going to measure this though?
&gt;&gt; So, what we're going to be doing is making a lot of comparisons. We're going to
have our 100 gram reference weight and our atheletes are going to be comparing
that to 101 grams and then a 102 grams, and for each of these comparisons,
they'll identify, or try to identify which is heavier.
&gt;&gt; That's fascinating, Andy.